talking about trans issues is one of the
most polarizing conversations you can
have these days and in many cases if not
most cases people seem to barely know
what they're talking about to be clear
for today I'm gonna be talking about
transgender people not transformers
while they're both more than meets the
eye I'm not here to talk about Autobots
and Decepticons so let's discuss
transgender people and the entire
whirlwind debate around their very
existence what comes to mind immediately
when you mentioned trans issues is the
North Carolina law that was the outrage
of the month when Republican Governor
Pat McCrory signed House bill to putting
into policy a statewide plan to ban
individuals from using public bathrooms
that did not correspond to their
biological sex immediately the media
went bonkers and McCrory and basically
the whole state of North Carolina were
labeled transphobic bigots which of
course was followed by the usual feeding
frenzy of partisan hackery the narrative
quickly became either you want creepy
adult men to be able to be in a woman's
bathroom with a little girl or you hate
trans people maroon5 demi lovato Bruce
Springsteen and other entertainers
canceled concerts in North Carolina and
the NBA even pulled the all-star game
scheduled in 2017 out of the state so
let's back up here for just a second
first off transgender people are an
absurdly tiny minority within the
country and the world
this doesn't mean they should be ignored
but the virtue signalling coming from
celebrities and pundits was totally
overblown why should all of the people
of North Carolina be punished for the
actions of their governor yeah they
voted him in but should every
politician's decision decide how a whole
state full of individual people is
treated and I don't think so how many of
the people who were part of the outrage
machine even know a transgender person
or have volunteered at a LGBT Center or
donated to their cause I'm guessing very
few but showing outrage instead of
actually helping people in a
constructive way is apparently how you
demonstrate how good of a person you are
in 2016 so let's unpack exactly what
happened in North Carolina for just a
second first off trans people have been
using whichever bathroom they see fit in
North Carolina and every other state for
as long as they've existed and as far as
I know there hasn't been a widespread
problem relating to them going into the
bathroom of their choice and if there
has been a problem
it probably has been violence directed
at the trans person themselves not the
other way around so in effect the
Republican House and Senate of North
Carolina decided to pass a law to stop
the presumed issue where there was no
ample evidence of a problem in the first
place in short it seemed more about
moralizing about the existence of
transgender people than passing a law
which really needed to be passed and by
the way aren't Republicans supposed to
be for individual liberty and small
government well creating laws about
bathrooms doesn't seem to be in line
with limited government thinking at any
level whatsoever now don't worry I'm not
gonna let the Democrats get off the hook
here either in response to this
misguided law President Obama issued a
federal directive on how public schools
should deal with transgender kids use of
the bathroom saying that kids should be
allowed to go into whichever bathroom
they see fit I believe Obama's actions
were well-intentioned and the president
was trying to protect this tiny minority
of transgender students but his response
in effect was another power grab by the
federal government actually it could be
argued that this directive by Obama is a
direct violation of the Tenth Amendment
which states that any power not
specifically delegated to the federal
government in the Constitution goes back
to the States
ultimately this case in which
Republicans made an issue where no issue
existed allowed a Democratic president
to take power away from the local state
government and put it in hands of the
Fed long story short this is a perfect
just a perfect example of how
dysfunctional our political system has
become I should back up here for just a
second and actually address trans people
instead of making this all about the
government
from the trans people that I know to
everything I've read and heard about
them trans people seem to just want to
live the most authentic life they can
pretty much just like the rest of us
imagine for one moment that you weren't
born into the body corresponding with
the sex that you felt that you were none
of us who aren't going through this
horrific and truly existentially
conflicting experience can have any clue
what this is like that in and of itself
is enough for me as a liberal to have
compassion for trans people and want to
help them in their struggle for the same
dignity that we all want of course a
libertarian who might not care about
trans people one way or another could
come to the exact same conclusion by
arguing that the government has no right
to dictate which bathroom a person goes
into this like with gay marriage and
legalizing marijuana is another in the
long line of issues where I see a new
political center aligning people who
want to do good by their fellow man
coupled with people who want to rein in
the power of the government are coming
to the same conclusions based on respect
of the individual and that's an
incredibly beautiful thing
I believe this new coalition of people
coming together despite political
differences is exactly what could be the
antidote for our obviously broken
political system my guest this week is
Blair White a YouTube personality who
yes so happens to be trans and she's
also a men's rights activist adding MRA
to the equation really flips the
oppression Olympics on its head and you
guys know I'm all about that I'm looking
forward to having a wide-ranging
conversation with Blair about her own
personal journey the battle for equality
her unique position on men's rights as
someone who is assigned male at birth
but now identifies as a woman and much
more I doubt she'll have all the answers
I certainly know that I won't have all
of them and that's exactly why we have
to have these important conversations
my guest this week is a youtuber a
free-speech activist immense rights
activists and more than meets the eye
Blair white welcome to the Rubin report
hi Dave thanks for having me thanks for
doing this you know every couple weeks I
suddenly get a burst of tweets where
people are saying this is the person you
got to talk to now and you were the
person over the past couple weeks that
everyone said you've got to talk to
Blair let's make it happen
yeah ever since I started YouTube I've
gotten a ton of people saying that we
need to do a talk we need to you know
collaborate on something so I don't have
a friendly doing it yeah all right well
we do have a lot in common in terms of
all the social justice stuff and free
speech stuff and you really put yourself
out there and totally unapologetic then
you let it fly so I'm looking forward to
this so let's start with some of the
trans stuff because I feel like you're
probably bored in some way by talking
about it but it does kind of frame a
little bit of this maybe maybe you're
not bored I don't want to put words in
your mouth when did you realize that you
were trans so the realization that I was
transgender I definitely came a little
bit later in life when I was younger I
definitely had a feeling of you know
disconnects between myself perception
and the way that other people interacted
with me as early as probably four or
five I remember feeling like something
just wasn't right I couldn't necessarily
put my finger on it or you know I figure
out what the word for it was as I got
older I kind of realized that I was able
to take my life into my own hands and do
what the medical medical community calls
transition and you know live my life how
I saw fit yeah so when did you first you
know you're four or five years old you
realize something's a little different
or a little off or however I want to
phrase it like what do you have idea of
an example of like what made you think
there's something going on here I
remember being in kindergarten and
feeling like all the activities that
were you know segregated amongst the
sexes I always had a natural inclination
to want to do what the girls were
assigned to do in there you know putting
backpacks away and the pink and blue
cubbies I always wanted to pink one not
because it was an aesthetic thing like
oh I like pink it was more because I
literally felt like that was where I was
supposed to be yeah and then what about
as you got a little bit older so now
you're you're four or five you're now
maybe in like
your high was with those trends just
continuing or was there anything else
that was popping up yeah that thread
definitely continued throughout my life
once I started to get a little bit
closer to puberty so like junior high I
started noticing some bodily changes
obviously puberty and that was when I
started to develop what they call gender
dysphoria and that is basically feeling
like I said the disconnect between your
body and the way people perceive you
yeah so I realized through going through
that that I needed to transition and as
I got older and how the financial means
I definitely put that into motion yeah
when you realize that you wanted to
transition did you know what it was
exactly because I think one of the
reasons that I think so much of when we
talk about transgender people and these
issues people don't even understand like
the basic stuff between what a
crossdresser is and what a transgendered
person is or you know all of this gets
lumped together as part of the LGBTQ eye
community and there's a lot of
differences within those letters did you
realize oh this is actually something
that I can do yeah definitely as I got
older you know the desire to transition
wasn't necessarily that it was more of
like I'm not comfortable with the way my
body is changing I'm not comfortable the
way the world is perceiving me and it
took learning what transitioning was to
understand well this might be my ticket
you know being being happy and it
definitely was you know I'm not one of
those people don't have those trans
people who thinks that anyone who feels
any type of you know dysphoria or
whatever need to transition I think it's
the wrong decision for some people and
some people do regret it I think that
there is a small number of people who
transition is the right decision
through-and-through I happen to be one
of those people I think it's it's where
it got pretty well for me but I do
acknowledge that it's not the smartest
thing for everyone that's interesting so
you think there are some trans people
who could be potentially in the same
sort of situation that you were in but
actually going through the process might
not altom utley be the best situation
for them
yeah I mean if you look at the suicide
rates for the trans community they're
extremely high and a lot of times
they're almost the same
even after transition so for that reason
it makes me think well maybe transition
isn't the right choice for everyone
that's just my opinion
obviously I'm a believer in freedom
Liberty you know do what you want with
your body live your life the way you
want I just don't like the idea that
anyone who feels like they're feminine
if they're males should you know alter
their body I don't think that's a good
route for everyone yeah you know the
suicide rate post transitioning is sort
of interesting because it's almost like
a lot a certain amount of these people I
would assume they think that suddenly at
the end of that road is the golden
ticket right it's the pot of gold where
all of their problems are gonna be
solved but there's still a lot of work
to be done after right yeah I mean
transition is just the beginning of your
life you know I didn't transition
because that was gonna be you know the
goal post I transitioned because okay
let me get this out of the way and then
focus on my career and focus on living
my life and just being a normal person I
think that a lot of people you know I've
been pretty lucky that trend the string
didn't come super difficult for me um I
had the means to you know do what I
wanted to do and I'm still doing what I
want to do but for a lot of people their
entire life is working their minimum
wage job and saving up for a surgery
that costs fifty thousand dollars and
all these treatments and what they
realize when they're done with that is
well not much has actually changed
physically yes but my life is still in
the gutter I've emptied my bank accounts
doing this and [ __ ] still sucks for me
right that that's really kind of
fascinating I don't think people frame
it that way usually so like you
literally have your life you have
whatever job you have whatever friends
you have you save up all of this money
you still have sort of the same problems
you may be in in the body you want to be
but the the physical part of your life
and your finances and all that and your
family or all that that's still all the
same so there's still a lot that has to
be done yeah there's so much more to
life than you know what you look like
and I'm not trivializing transgender as
I'm like it's just about what you look
like but at the same time transition is
just changing what you look like
and there's just so much more to life
yeah it's interesting you use the word
normal a second ago which I know in this
conversation sometimes when you say that
to people you say well they they just
want to be normal or I just want to be
normal or that but that triggers people
that phrase normal but I'm guessing it
doesn't trigger you because you used it
so it's it's okay yeah yeah I mean I
will be the first to say being
transgender is abnormal it's abnormal
it's it's not common it's your if you're
transgender you're an extremely small
minority it's not it's just not
mainstream so but I don't think that
abnormal is necessarily a negative
descriptor I just think it's not the
status quo it's just not the status quo
yeah I like that so let's talk about how
it's sort of become mainstream because
very quickly you know it seemed to me
that for for gay rights although it
obviously took a long time suddenly
within like a five year span it became
like cool and then marriage happened and
it's all good now you know I mean yes
there's still there's still problems of
course but you know it's it's pretty
good for gay people in most Western
societies certainly in America right now
not to say it's perfect but it's pretty
good the trans the trans issue happened
so quickly on the heels of gay marriage
a lot because of Caitlyn Jenner so what
did you make of just sort of the I guess
the transitioning of Caitlyn Jenner
someone doing it so publicly and then
also the just the media thing that went
on behind that yeah you know it was
really interesting for trans people to
watch that go down I mean it was like
watching I don't even know what but what
was really interesting to me was when
Caitlyn Jenner came out she was heralded
as this like brave amazing person she
was beautiful she was studying she was
just everything people wanted in the
trans person and then she sort of
started opening her mouth and people
realized like oh she's still a
conservative yeah she's a Republican
which is well yeah that's worse than
being trans yeah and people will turn on
her completely she's the most hated
person because before it was just like
the super far-right conservatives that
were like
I don't like that now it's everyone
because everyone hates me you know
everyone hates conservatives right I
guess conservatives don't hate
conservatives I think most people
secretly don't but this this PC machine
has us all tricked into into who we hate
but we'll get to that in a little bit do
you think there's a risk when when
something happens so quickly this is
partly what I've seen that people didn't
know much about trans issues because as
you said it's a it's a very very tiny
minority now I would be for protecting
any minority in any way that you can but
that when something becomes so public so
quickly that everyone kind of goes crazy
about it so for in the Caitlyn example
it's like she came out and then it was
like everybody suddenly was the trans
Ally and trans hero and it was almost it
seemed like virtue signaling more than
something that seemed real to me oh
absolutely I mean listen I think that as
a trans person you can't have this
expectation that everyone is going to I
understand you because how could they
and be accept you because why would they
it's literally it's just being trans
like I said earlier there's so much more
to being a person like for me someone
being trans or not being trans or being
straight or being gay it's like okay but
what do you do like who argued what are
your actual averred she was beyond trans
as amazing and everyone should accept it
what are your real virtues that's what's
important to me it's almost like you
care about the individual what a radical
thought yeah total radical thought all
right so obviously if we're talking
about trans issues we have to talk about
the the bathroom law in North Carolina
when I at the top of the show I sort of
laid it out for everybody and I'm
guessing you're not you're obviously not
for the law correct I'm not for or
against the law I I genuinely I feel
like I'm speaking for a lot of trans
people right now I don't usually feel
comfortable saying now that I speak for
anyone but I feel like in saying this
I'm comfortable saying this most people
don't care most of us do not care who's
going into what bathroom etc I think
that both sides of the political
spectrum really you know brought this
into something that it really didn't
need to be I mean trans people have used
the bathrooms for as long as there's
been
and no one's had an issue um I don't
know the left was pushing warning like
gender-neutral bathrooms which is a war
trans people did not ask them to fight
we don't want in a neutral bathrooms we
just want to use the revealer bathrooms
we don't want to you know find
businesses for not you know spending all
their money to build these new bathrooms
and the right with making it seem like
you know this huge rapist area which was
also fallacious it was just all so silly
to me just like the Kaelin thing it's
interesting as a trans person to sit and
watch the media circus around these
issues when I just living really yeah
you're just trying to live your life and
as you said I love the way you frame
that and it's art it's partly what I
said at the top of the show but it's
like you and every other trans person
for a long time has been using whatever
bathroom they felt was appropriate and
as far as I know there wasn't some
massive problem related to this so you
have a Republican legislature that makes
it a problem and then you have the
federal government come in and say well
we're gonna start cutting funding if you
don't do what we want and I don't think
you're for bigger government in a case
like this either right no absolutely not
and you know that's an important thing
to note because the left like I said
often fights words that we don't ask
them to and for instance in New York Bay
I believe have sort of fining people for
not using proper pronouns and that's not
even just including key and she it's
like ziens urn right it's like trans
people already have an unemployment rate
that's I think like three or four times
the national average and so you're
really screwing over trans people by
pushing this you know brunchy
legislation but basically by adding you
know a liability on the head of anyone
they want to hire that might be trans
yes they often screw over the people
that they're claiming to fight for in
their co-opting yeah I mean I'm pretty
sure you know my feelings on this
because this is what the left has done
in a lot of ways so really this does
this strike you as sort of the road to
hell is paved with good intentions I I
believe that a good portion of the
people on the left that are pushing for
all this stuff they think they're
helping people like you yeah but but in
a weird way they're actually
objectifying you for
ultimately what becomes bigger
government and more control yeah I mean
as much as I make fun of straight-up use
on my channel I think that a lot of them
do have their hearts in the right place
I just think that they go about it
completely wrong and they actually like
you said do harm the people they're
co-opting a lot more than they help them
okay so with the with the law out of the
way and sort of your personal story out
of the way before we get to a whole
bunch other stuff which is the stuff
that I really want talking about is
there anything else directly related to
the two being trans or the public idea
of trans or any of that but maybe I
might have missed here that that the
average person isn't thinking about well
I think you know something I say in a
lot of interviews is that there seems to
be this misconception that
transgenderism is the offspring of third
wave feminism of this you know riots and
social justice this but it's not the
case I'm trans people have been around
long before otherwise of the SJW is
along before our third wave feminism and
it's not you know a feminist issue it's
just people like I've been saying yeah
okay so you transition your your when
when will you actually finish resisting
around 20 it's kind of weird to think
like finished auditioning I mean it can
always be things that you want to do but
in terms of just living my life yeah
woman I mean then yeah I accomplished
that probably within starting so that's
pretty quick okay so you do that and now
you as you said you're 22 years old when
did you decide that I'm going to be
someone that talks about this it's one
thing to live my life as you said but
now you either I'm gonna put myself out
there and I'm gonna take pretty
unpopular opinions or at least opinions
that are contrary to what the media will
constantly push a trans person should be
like well I decided to start my channel
because I was like I said earlier which
is sick of being co-opted I was sick of
actually aw is having this monopoly on
anything trans I mean anyone who wants
to check it out now Google anything to
do with transgenderism the only things
that pop up pretty much besides some
actual scientific studies are you know
tumblr pages and you know leftist media
I didn't like that my identity was being
you know politicized by them so that was
kind of the main reason and then also
you know they're just topics I find
interesting you know I actually don't
talk about transgenderism that much on
my channel yeah I German ISM Islam black
lives matter a lot of different things
so it was kind of just a means to speak
my mind yeah all right well we're gonna
we're gonna dive into all that stuff
don't worry about it I'm not letting you
get out of here without going into some
of that stuff at least yeah well if you
get into trouble it's on you not at me
but so when you decided to do the public
part of this how did you have any
pushback from friends or family or were
you concerned about your safety at all
or anything like that
oh you know yeah once you decided to put
these videos out there yeah yeah stuff
went down when I started my youtube um
people will often comment on my channel
saying like oh you're trans so you can
say all these things that I can't say as
a straight white male actually I think
it's the opposite I think I get way more
blowback because I'm trans and I am
speaking out against you know Ashley W
is I think that they often see me as a
traitor of sorts and so the amount of
how I got from starting YouTube was
crazy I lost a ton of friends I have
feminists trying to get me a victim from
my apartment at the time my roommates
were awful to me so it wasn't easy
starting it but luckily I'm in a good
situation now living with my boyfriend
and I can do my videos and whatever but
definitely push back yeah isn't that
interesting the so called tolerant side
once you start speaking about what you
as an individual thing suddenly not so
tolerant huh yeah yeah I mean they have
they had this whole spiel about like
supporting trans voices and making trans
voices heard but really they mean trans
wishes if they're on my side of the
political spectrum that's what they
really mean right so in a way Caitlyn
Jenner for you really has has blazed two
trails in a way by sort of normalizing
some trans stuff in general but really
on the political side I don't think
you're a conservative but you seem to me
that you're either a libertarian or
you're for freedom that seems to be the
general thing in your for the individual
but by her taking that position as we
said earlier kind of flip there
on its head so she's really like blazing
trails all over the place which is
that's what you're supposed to do right
or am I wrong on that one what do you
think I don't know I think that she's
done more trans people too I think that
um I think that a lot of conservatives
don't like her I think she's has a lot
of really weird things and just her
behavior is really weird and the fact
that the biggest conservative trans icon
like killed someone in a car perfect you
know yeah no one's perfect sometimes we
just kill people on accident but um you
know I can't say she's blades any trails
for me I don't think my life's been
become easier or harder because of her
media presence I think that I don't know
yeah she is what she is I think that
she's right about some things you know
but she she's Caitlyn she's right right
right I guess I guess really at the end
of the day this is the risk with any
movement when you when so much of it is
based on one person that person can't
represent everything for everybody as I
don't think you or as you've already
said you don't try to represent anyone
other than yourself
no no if people feel like I'm saying
things that they want to say but can't
then that's great but I am solely
speaking for Blair that's why in this
interview I'm talking about trans stuff
I don't want anyone to think that I'm
speaking as if though it's some sort of
monolith and my experience with
everyone's because it's just not the
case yeah I'm curious so you mentioned
you have a boyfriend did he know that
you had transition before you met or did
he know who you were before he met or
how about that no I told them with him I
think like the first 24 hours of talking
to him online and yeah he knew right
away it was it was after I started
transitioning yeah one other thing on
the trans stuff and then we're going to
move into other stuff I promise I've my
friend Janet mock who I've interviewed a
couple times you know Janet I don't know
but you know who she is yeah
one of the things that she said to me I
had her on my old Sirius XM show years
ago before Caitlyn Jenner was out when
people really weren't talking about
trans stuff and one of the things she
said to me that I thought was
particularly interesting is that when
she transitioned that because she really
does pass she's really beautiful and
because of that it makes the experience
that much easier because people aren't
constantly looking at her and
questioning and that and that's only
gonna happen to a really pretty small
amount of people do you think that's
fair to say yeah and and so what does
that then do to the to the average
person you think that that transitions
because I think you're probably closer
to her side of that and I think a lot of
people probably transition and they're
looking for perfection on the other side
and it goes to what we said before about
their finding this pot of gold but it
never really can be there yeah I think
that what we call passing just means you
know being able to live your life and
not being perceived as your original sex
I think that it makes life easier I
think that a lot of the people who don't
past are the ones who seem to be a lot
of you know they have a lot of
bitterness but I mean it's kind of to be
expected I mean it does suck if you were
to live your life and just everyone is
looking at you strange everywhere you go
I mean for any reason trans or not if
you have some sort of deformity or
whatever it would suck alright so let's
move on to the social justice warrior
piece of this because I spent the last
week watching a ton of your videos I had
seen many of them before and you just do
a great job because you fearless leap it
yourself out there and as you've said
repeatedly already you're not
representing anyone other than yourself
but you're talking about some serious
stuff you're talking about Islam and
black lives matter and feminism these
are these are pretty controversial
things so let's start with well first
off I guess when did you realize what a
problem the SJW the social justice
warrior stuff had become was it directly
related to the trans stuff where had you
seen those sort of themes because of all
the world of tumblr and the rest of it
well right around the time that I was
starting my channel a lot of things were
happening in the media I don't know if
you remember there was someone named
Stephanie or Stefani um they were like a
trans ager it was like a 45 year old man
who identified as like a six year old
girl yeah I've seen some videos on that
yeah yeah complete degenerate
and the leftist media was pushing
stories about it and you know talking
about how it was brave and amazing and I
thought that was super disturbing and
then I was also around the time when New
York started finding people for not
using the right pronouns and I was like
okay these people like I said earlier I
fighting wars that I did not ask them to
fight and I just wanted to you know
speak my mind about it and then you know
there's also other components as well I
don't like how feminism in sjw's tends
to completely ignore men's issues which
is one of the first topics I touched on
on my channel and how they have all
these you know apologetics when it comes
to Islam there's a lot of stuff yeah and
it's all kind of tied together so let's
start with feminism because you've been
pretty outspoken against feminism or at
least what feminism has become so can
you lay that out for me yeah basically I
have sort of an objection to the
ideological framework in which feminism
operates under which places women as an
entirely separate social class than men
and places women is sort of a victim
status which I've been around strong
women my entire life I've never found
this to be true that women are some sort
of damsels in distress and I actually
think it's kind of sexist to place them
in that in that place mm-hmm I also
didn't like how feminism you know well
virtue signal when they're confronted
about men's issues and saying to care
about it when they don't do anything
tangible to actually help men's issues
and help men so those are really main
objections to feminism right so then you
became a men's rights activist and as a
someone that has transitioned and is a
woman
this really flips a lot of things on its
head because people would think that you
would be the reverse for some reason I
think that would be traditional thinking
but when did you realize that you wanted
to become part of the men's rights
movement and actually first can you just
describe what you think men the men's
right activism what is it really because
I think a lot of people don't know yeah
yeah well first of all when I started my
channel I definitely you know waive the
MRA flag you know men's rights after
this fog I've kind of stepped away from
calling myself of that because I don't I
feel like sometimes when I label myself
or when anyone labels themselves they
sort of fall into the trap of
confirmation bias and I don't want to
feel like I have any sort of alliance
with any sort of groups I just take each
issue individually and digest it and
make my opinion for my opinion but I
definitely do care about men's issues
and I still talk about them on my
channel I it comes close it's close to
home because I have a half-brother who
has been to jail for domestic violence
and his wife had no scratches on her she
completely lied about it
and she was able to get him arrested
just on claims I also care a lot about
inequities in divorce court at family
courts male suicide I don't like the
stigma around male victims of rape and
molestation it's kind of a lot of things
there's a huge crisis in education for
men and boys are falling behind there
really is a lot of issues I'm like I
said feminism just doesn't even touch on
them they claim to you but they don't
right so I think that sort of
conventional thinking on this is that
men have kind of been in charge of the
world for so long that even if some of
those issues that you just mentioned are
true you know claims and divorces and
jail and this and that that I sense that
there's a certain amount of people with
leftist thinking and some of these
social justice worries
that would just say well you know what
suck it up men it your time is over now
obviously that's not saying I subscribe
to you but do you think that's where
it's coming from with them yeah but but
I mean I think that line of thinking is
super dumb I think that there's the past
and there's the present and things
change and people have to change with it
we have to realize that there are issues
that face men now but they didn't face
yesterday and kind of move forward with
that because at the end of the day the
pendulum did swings too far and were
kind of still in this state of trying to
convince people that the pendulum swung
too far yeah I would imagine that out of
all the things that you talked about
that this is probably the one you would
get the most hate for and we're gonna
get into some of the other ones in a sec
but would you think that's fair to say
no I think by far the biggest one that
I've gotten blowback from was black
lives matter really so not even Islam so
alright let's let's shift Islam for a
second so you just did a video that I
watched where basically you said that
being an Islamophobe is not a bad thing
and then you laid out a case for that so
can you kind of can you kind of break
down that video and then we'll link to
it below so people can get to it yeah I
mean my question would be like I'm
transgender why would I not be afraid of
Islam I mean like I said this video the
implications behind the word
Islamophobia as if somehow it's a
rational to fear Islam which is an
ideology that calls for my brutal death
I'm not sure why I wouldn't be afraid of
that I mean I would not be able to exist
peacefully in the Middle Eastern country
under Islamic law really I can only
exist in Western society where people
feel how they want to feel about trans
people there's definitely people who
wouldn't like him solely for that reason
but there is a general consensus that I
have a right to live my life as I see
fit if I'm not hurting anyone else and
that is what allows me to be here right
so when you're talking about this you
definitely to me are making the
distinction which I always try to make
between Islam which is just a set of
ideas that can be criticized like any
other set of ideas and people who live
as Muslims and there are plenty of
Muslim people who as individuals would
certainly not care or want to harm you
in any way or who might fall in love
with you or anything else or who could
be your biggest fans but you're saying
that we're we're the rules of Islam are
in place this is something that it is
legitimate to fear it is not phobic to
fear you're not you're not prejudging
your your post judging yeah anywhere
that Islam is codified into law is a
horrible place to live in terms of human
rights I mean that's just an objective
truth like obviously there are
exceptions but even in those exceptions
it's just not up to par with the
freedoms that you can have in Western
society obviously I've met many many
Muslims who are perfectly fine no issue
the thing is I think you and I agree on
this like it's important to separate
people from ideas it's not you know that
you hate Muslims because you're a
criticizing Islam it's just the idea of
Islam not the person who follows it I
mean look I always say it's like I do
not I would only judge people on their
individual feelings there you know I
mean if you're trying to behead me or if
you're trying to subjugate women
then I have a problem with you but if
you privately believe whatever you want
to believe whether it's in Muhammad or
Moses or the Spaghetti Monster or Jesus
or who else is there it's by a couple
other good ones right yeah but that's
the difference between us and Ashley W
is there the thought police you know
like it's not enough for people to you
know accept trans people like in their
own hearts whatever you have to have to
believe show it yes you know what I mean
like it's like everyone has to be an
activist or you're part of the problem
that really is the difference you know
yeah you know it's funny I saw on real
time a couple weeks ago Bill Maher did
an interesting piece about the left and
he was saying you guys are always
finding little dirt in a room that you
demand to sweep up meanwhile the hall
the whole buildings burning down and I
think that's really why you're
describing it's like you have all these
people who their general ideology is
pretty much the same but they're finding
little ways to fight with each other as
there's actual issues that were
completely ignoring in terms of for all
the trans people or LGBT people or women
or other minorities that are in all of
these places that are ruled by Islam
it's horrible for all of them but I
don't see any one on the left doing
anything about that no absolutely and
it's just like you touched on I mean
it's not enough to accept trans people
and you know not discriminate against
them if you accidentally misgender them
you're automatically a transfer it's and
they could be constantly I mean it's
just it's in the word of what they
describe micro aggressions absolutely
microscopic you have to search for it to
find it if you have to search for it
it's not a problem
yeah so wait let's jump into the micro
aggression thing and trigger warnings
and safe spaces and all that so I know I
know you're as against them as I am but
as someone that's younger than me did
you when did you see this actually
starting like when you were in high
school was this concept bubbling up
there cuz when I was in high school it
did not exist at all no I'm really young
and I didn't even see you in high school
I thought when I got to college that was
when I started seeing it and I started
seeing you know it was like everyone at
my school had to be liberal social
justice warrior or you were kind of
blacklisted and it was kind of like you
know that's that person and we're what
and we're you know constantly brought in
signaling and we're great people that's
kind of what it was um I saw a lot of
bias in college classrooms and I think
it spawns in college more than high
school but yeah yeah so what do you make
of going back to Islam for just a sec
that Islam seems to have been put at the
top of this oppression Olympics that we
talk about all the time so you as it so
trans is high on there but it's actually
lower than Islam to me the the SJW
people the the regression people all
this their highest place in the
oppression Olympics is Islam which
actually is the most regressive and
against progressive ideals of all of
these ideologies so what is going on in
their well-intentioned brains absolutely
nothing Trump's Islam on the oppression
Olympics it's really crazy how they
really are like you said completely on
the opposite end of what they believe in
on pretty much everything yeah yeah and
I really I genuinely don't understand it
like I've talked about the support like
why is it I think it's simply because
they are dumb enough to conflate Islam
with brown people many people at all
cost I think that's what it is I think
it's that simple they're brown so they
win which is which is not only there's
actually a degree of racism related to
that but it's also it's terribly sloppy
thinking because guess what there are
brown Christians and there are brown
Jews and there are brown atheists and
everything else so they're attaching an
ideology to a to a racial connotation
which is which is silly and nonsensical
and one of the things I saw you know the
Olympics is happening right now and our
friend Lalo tweeted out a pic
retweeted a picture that some writer had
posted and it was I believe it was a
woman from Iran and a woman from America
in beach volleyball and the American
woman I think it was an American woman
you know she's it just in a bikini as
always welt and you know great body
bikini and the Iranian woman was in
you know the hijab and the whole thing
and the guy wrote something to the
effect of there's nothing wrong with
this and and Lauer wrote something like
well actually one culture is forcing
women to do that and I thought this just
to me is the perfect example of the the
virtue signal that I don't have a
problem in and of itself with this woman
wearing that stuff but it has to be
purely her decision to do so and she has
to be just as free to wear the bikini so
that American woman could wear a hijab
and cover up completely but she is the
choice to do either and it's just not
true that the other woman has purely the
choice even though in this specific case
maybe she did but I suspect not and and
this is the the crux of the problem you
think that's fair to say yeah absolutely
and people pretend like the job is you
know a choice over there and it's just
religious expression no they don't have
a choice and it's incredibly
uncomfortable I mean I would imagine
I've never worn one but I would imagine
it's [ __ ] hot and for the hair I
think it's not it's not as if you know
it's just a different culture I think
some cultures are objectively better
than others yeah and I'm not saying you
can't wear it but you it should be up to
you that's why it's always women that
are put in these things right like
that's true oppression right it's not
women forcing men to wear weird things
it's always been forcing women so
doesn't that show you a little bit of
the power play there yeah I mean
feminism is completely silent on you
know issues regarding women in the
Middle East which i think is insane I
think that the fact that that's another
one of my huge problems with feminism
they focus like you said on the small
little corner in the room of the dirt
and they don't focus on what's actually
happening you know like like you said
microaggression man's playing man
spending all this [ __ ] and women in
other countries are suffering it's like
they only focus on America and we don't
have that many problems here yeah in
terms of women and you know oppression
of women we don't really have anything
wrong yeah not to say we can't get
better at some things but oh man so what
did you make because to me the biggest
example of what you're talking about was
New Year's in Germany when there was the
mass sex attack and and rapes and
they're still trying to figure out what
happened in the media
covered it up but it obviously turned
out to be a lot of the migrants and the
new immigrants that have come from Syria
and actually they've come from all over
the place because it's very unclear
where they're coming from because of
some of the laws that Merkel's placed in
terms of immigration but immediately I
saw people on the left not defending
women they were actually throwing women
under the bus but immediately defending
Islam now we've already talked about for
whatever reason they hold Islam at the
highest but isn't that the most anti
woman thing you could do women are our
mothers and our sisters and our
girlfriends and wives and their
immediate reaction was not to defend the
people who had been attacked but to
defend an ideology that had led the
attackers to doing it I mean it's it's
just the most backwards thing you could
do I mean it's a sickness it's this this
I mean I've read articles about you know
Swedish women who were raped and they
don't tell the authorities because they
know that the person who raped them was
a migrant and they think that you know
they don't want to contribute to racism
I mean it's a complete sickness it's so
wrong I think that the idea like we said
I think this is it's just the brown
person thing you know right now with
everything black lives matter in the
media everyone is rushing to defend
brown people at all costs
and Islam they happen to complete that
with brown people all right so let's
talk about black lives matter and you I
think you've done a couple videos on
black lives matter and my feeling is
that the movement has changed again from
what I would describe as something that
was well-intentioned trying to deal with
some seriously big problems related to
law enforcement and their treatment of
the black community that I think most
people realize is somewhat legitimate at
some level right I'm trying to come
trying to be somewhat politically
correct here I guess but it seems to
have morphed into something else
so you know just the other day I saw a
video of a guy in New York City Park who
was wearing a trump hat he that's well
within his right to wear a trump hat and
black lives matter people a good group
but probably 50 or hundred people were
literally forcing him out of the park
getting right in his face you know
pushing him a little bit all this up
anything that he's a threat to free
speech and democracy a guy just
expressing a political opinion with the
Hat and I've seen the movement sort of
morph into more of that
then I think what it should be about or
is supposed to be about absolutely I
think like it said the movement has
changed I think the movement has become
super toxic I think like most social
movements that begin with you know an
idea that is well-intentioned and maybe
we even should talk about it I think
police brutality is the actual topic
that needs to be discussed and I think
it's a shame that black lives matter has
kind of made it so a lot of people don't
want to talk about it um it's right with
a good intention and then like most
leaderless movements it really just took
a crowd you know I mean what we see is
that they don't actually care about
black lives I'm have you seen that young
I think that's like a 17 year olds who I
think he did like an interview one
Infowars or something and he's a trump
supporter and right now there's people
like from black lives matter like
searching for him I did see it
unbelievable that kid yeah it's it's
insane and all the wild hashtagging
black lives matter while they're hunting
down a black person simply because they
want to vote for Trump it's it's crazy
but I did make videos about black lives
matter
I made one entitled you know straight to
the point I entitled it black lives
matter is trashed
and I got huge blowback from that and
obviously was shared amongst black lives
matter you know obviously my viewership
enjoyed it but about desire did not and
there was a huge dog sing Fiasco they're
trying to Doc's me I had to go off
social media I saw that you tweeted that
you thought I had been banned from
Twitter oh my god it's reasonable
because a lot of us were being banned
lately but it wasn't the case I was
actually kind of just laying low mater
was trying to ruin my life
yeah so for the people that are in it
with the with all the internet lingo so
you are doxed which basically means
somebody pretty much they found out
where you live right and probably made
that information public and they can get
all other sorts of it's we're not just
your physical location but they can get
banking records and all kinds of stuff I
mean this is a huge threat to free
speech because once you have this sort
of blackmail on people and then they go
after someone who publicly is saying
things that are unpopular but it's the
chilling effect I mean that's my thing
with the Mylo thing I want my low back
on Twitter for many
and I miss his voice on there but to me
it's the chill effect of okay we got rid
of Milo how many other people are gonna
stop saying what you think regardless of
whether I agree with them or not yeah
absolutely you know even aside from
Twitter banning people you voice any
type of conservative view the daxing is
effective to free speech I mean we use
intimidation or threats of violence to
silence someone that is literally
stifling free speech so I mean I didn't
let it stop me I just went lay low for
two days or whatever and then I came
back and I doubled down with another
video sometimes matter but now I
understand why a lot of people when they
do YouTube videos they use anonymous
pictures and names because it actually
is difficult to you know stamp your name
on something I think you know it means
more when you do stamp rhenium on
something but there's also a huge risk
that goes along with that yeah you know
I struggle with that big time because
people message me all the time saying
you know you're so brave you're putting
this stuff out there free speech blah
blah blah and I'm just doing what I
think is right I don't think I'm
actually that special or anything I'm
just doing I got some thoughts firing
around up here and I and I say I'm and
that's really it but I do sometimes get
frustrated by the amount of people that
are in the Free Speech Movement that are
only doing it as anonymous people and I
get it
I get there's a real threat people feel
like if they say something I'm
politically correct they're gonna lose
their job or all that but in a weird way
does that show we're actually losing
because so many of us that are that are
trying to fight for what is what is real
equality what is real honesty and what
is really free speech feel the need
already to be anonymous which makes it
seem like it would only get worse even
though there's obviously some awakening
going on here yeah honestly you know I
talked about this the other day with
someone I do think in a sense it does
mean that we we have a huge battle ahead
of us the fact that most of us don't
stamp our name on it because it has huge
social implications I mean I told you
about you know how feminists tried to
get me a victim from where I was living
black lives matter trying to DOX me and
I lost a shitload of friends I could
imagine that what I say online if I
wasn't doing YouTube full-time if I were
to go apply for a job at wherever I
would have difficulty doing that and so
it's I think there's something to be
said for the fact that you google
feminist youtubers everyone will have
their full name picture all that if you
google you know anti feminism anti Islam
and Chewbacca's matter everyone has like
a cartoon picture yeah
god it's so clear to me and especially
when I talk to someone like you it's
just so clear to me that we're on the
right side of this because we're having
a consistent set of principles that were
standing for which is actually for the
minority and the free thinker and for
the actual Muslim person and for the
trans person because we want these
people to all be treated equally not
specially and we have got to crush this
thing it just seems so obvious as I'm
talking to you know we have to you and
you know you brought it up I think we
actually are losing the fact that Milo
is banned the fact that a lot of us are
forced into anonymity a lot of us are
forced off the internet when we're doxed
I think it's more important than ever
then just to just speak but I understand
the implications that go along with that
yeah you know a couple times you've
mentioned that you've lost some friends
in this battle and I've said several
times on the show I lost a bunch of
friends when I started talking about
this too and and I gained a whole bunch
of new better friends so so that's okay
but I get emails all the time people
saying I'm losing friends or I can't
post this on Facebook or this one
blocked me or my sister won't talk to me
I mean really some crazy nonsense when
you lost friends can you give me an
example of like what that like one time
and how that conversation went because I
got I can give you example of like just
people that I've known for many many
years that's suddenly out of nowhere
Dave you're a bigot and a racist and I'm
not gonna talk to you anymore and and
then that's it and then stop responding
to texts and calls and it's like I don't
think I've said anything remotely
bigoted or racist I'm trying to have
hard conversations and it's just it's
just a sad state of affairs no it is I
think you and I might be somewhere in
the sense that being gay and being trans
a lot of our social circle was with
liberals and a lot of our social circle
was people who are more inclined to the
SJW mind
and so when it comes to starting to
break out of that it's kind of like
leaving a cult I'm just gonna be on it's
kind of like leaving a call I mean I
lost like at least 15 friends like in
one day first day at YouTube and all of
a sudden I noticed a shift and no one
talking to me some people actually
vocalizing that what I what I was doing
was so wrong and people talking about me
I think that a lot of people I've heard
a lot of messages as well people saying
they're losing family or they lost their
job I think it sucks it really sucks
yeah do you think politics has become
the new religion because it seems to me
that in the old days or for all time of
human history we were divided by
religions now we still have plenty of
religious division in the world without
question but it seems to me more than
ever right now and partially this is
because of I think our two crappy
candidates running and just our whole
political machine is broken in America
and all that but now people are being
divided on political lines we're in the
it used to be I know when I was growing
up my family table we had a big family
events every would be arguing over
politics and all believed in all kinds
of different things and we'd be
screaming and then at the end everybody
was fine and and we all went ahead and
love each other and that's it but now it
seems like if you have if you know
somebody that's a trump supporter that
somehow you're racist and you know
somebody that's a Hillary supporter
you're somehow a wall street sellout and
all that and it's like this is crazy
yeah I think it's also emotionally
charged I mean it's almost impossible to
have any type of political discourse
without people just freaking out on both
ends I'm not even gonna say it's like
just a no you know well I showed up you
think I think on both ends people take
it super seriously and you know I'm
probably go see of doing that sometimes
as well but I do make a conscious effort
to like not take everything so seriously
I mean objectively when I talk about our
serious topics but I think it's nice to
present them in a way that's just a
little bit light-hearted that's why a
lot of my videos are you know comedic in
nature because it's just everything's so
heavy lately I know everyone feels that
everything's just so heavy
yeah well isn't that the funny thing
about what they call [ __ ] posting online
it's like all of these people I'm not
saying you were doing
but when I see all these it is funny to
hear you saying [ __ ] posting online oh
well I'm trying to for the people that
don't know what [ __ ] posting is I was
trying that was for the older audience
you know I mean I know the kids know
what the chip posting is but basically
for people that don't know what [ __ ]
posting is it's basically intentionally
trying to inflame people to get them to
react and I see this all the time you
know I see all these these Trump Nazis
posting all this stuff and I see the
Frog and all this crap and to me it's
like either ignore it or I think some of
it's funny and some of it's scary and
annoying but it's like all right you're
some guy you did that you're not at my
house with a pitchfork but then they get
that they get celebrities and and
journalists and big-name people to react
and then it seems like there's something
much bigger going on here when really
all it is is some kid with Photoshop who
took Hitler and put him on Trump and
people go bananas and it's like really
you don't really do anything Leslie
Jones that's what happens Lee Jones it
was her this is why people say do not
feed the trolls because you know she was
fired of someone then everyone realized
oh we'll get a reaction then and so
we'll post about her being a gorilla and
we'll post about you know anything that
will humiliate her and she was then
going to war with these Twitter accounts
with like anime pictures and like people
who aren't you know it's funny and but
that's the reason why I Milo was banned
also which really sucks but the fact
that people really perceive it to be
that there's just this many like hate
will evil people when really it's just
people [ __ ] with you cuz it's the
Internet and you can't have high
expectations with the Internet that's
why a lot of people will ask me like how
do you deal with sex the hate comments
it's like see Internet it's not like I
would be depressed if I was walking down
the mall and someone just screams [ __ ]
at me but the internet it's not a big
deal that's what I always say and I've
really come around on this it's like if
some random nut bag with an anime
picture or a Twitter egg starts
screaming at me it's like listen if I
was walking down the street and some
crazy person started screaming at me I
would ignore them I wouldn't engage them
and have a battle of ideas with a crazy
person and yet people think if if a cat
does it to you you better respond or
you're gonna lose you know the
interesting thing about Leslie Jones by
the way is I didn't know this till
yesterday I have never interacted with
her I've never
during a tweet I've never I don't think
I've even ever said her name publicly
even when I did my video about Milo I'm
not even sure that I brought her up
specifically never interact with her I
just saw it yesterday that she has me
blocked on Twitter which kind of tells
you everything you need to know about
this this level of discourse I was going
to invite her on the show that's why I
went to check I was about to just say
come on in let's have an honest open
conversation the way I would do with
anyone else and she's got me blonde yeah
a lot of times they use blocks which is
basically like the automatic block
anyone who was a follower say Miley
innopolis so a lot of times that's what
happens as well like you'll come across
an actual aw and you you've never
interacted with them but they have you
block so that's what that is but that's
the whole you know echo-chamber thing
it's the whole I don't want to hear
anyone else's opinions I almost want to
spout my shed and no one can respond
which people think that that's like a
violation of free speech I don't think
that is I think that's a little dramatic
to say your own silence increase reach
because it's the internet everyone has
their own platform like it doesn't
matter how big or small it is everyone
can say what they want I mean I'm I'm
all for that say whatever the hell you
want as long as you're not calling for
direct violence or the or Daxing
someone's you know some without a direct
threat beyond that say whatever you want
and be the be the bigger person and if
somebody's saying something you don't
like they got the mute button or they
got the block button or just ignore them
and life will go on won't it yeah
absolutely yeah it is the internet well
you know what you you do so much what
you do on the internet and I love what
you do and I think you're doing such
great stuff yeah if you do did we miss
anything here I think we hit all the big
points I don't think so I think we talk
about a lot of stuff yeah when are you
when are you making it down to LA so we
can do this in person xn anytime anytime
I do YouTube full-time so my schedule is
pretty clear besides making videos so
that's pretty that's pretty sweet what
did you think it was gonna happen so
quickly that you could actually be a
full-time youtuber as they say no no I
mean listen the money is not I'm not
sitting here like I'm not sitting in the
pan for life it's a YouTube channel
people but at the same time you know I'm
able to support myself and just focus on
making videos now which is great so yeah
well that's all that's what it's all
about well it
for whatever it's worth even though I
don't even like the phrase a lie you
know you have an ally and me and I have
a feeling we'll continue to do some
stuff together and you guys can find out
more about Blair check out her totally
not politically correct YouTube channel
it's youtube.com slash Blair White X and
thanks Allah Blair thank you buddy